[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en suis à mon septembre
elle en est à son met et je
l'aime mon charbon m'interdit sa
luminosité et je
l'aime elle est belle à pasire et moi
vous me voyez et je
l'aime ses yeux sont un
matin la nuit m'a dévoyé et je l'aime et
je l'aime et je l'aime et ma cendre à
l'envers reconstitue la flamme et je
l'aime et mon cœur vieux tocar le voilà
qui rendame et je l'aime et j'entends
une vois me crier c'est ta femme ta
femme l'humain je le crachais
elle est la fleur humaine et je
l'aime je savais me haïr elle exténu la
haine et je l'aime je pelotis la mort
son ventre t la vie et je l'aime je
m'armis de mes
larmes deses armées elle ri et je l'aime
et je l'aime et je l'aime et je cours
dans les rues bondissant hors des drames
et je l'aime une Pise inconnue me peuple
d'or flamme et je l'aime et j'entends
cette voix affamée c'est ta
femme rendez-vous à 8h
elle arrive à 8h
toc toc toc en moi l'ancien Satan attend
qu'elle me leure pas du tout je lui dis
comme on dit je lui dis mes problèmes et
je l'aime je me peint tout bossu roué
sur la vie blême je t'aime je teaime je
t'aime je t'aime depuis que je t'ai vu
passer je teaime toi le Bel avenise
veux-tu de mon passé je te'aime mais je
suis tout petit oh maman oh
madame je vous
aime mon âme tne en
moi que vous êtes ma
[Musique]
femme que vous êtes ma femme
elle
[Musique]
m'ême